Gina's Britain's favorite spirit we
bought over 47 million bottles of it in
2017 distillation goes back to the ninth
century when Arabian alchemists
developed the Alembic still this
produced highly alcoholic spirits which
could be infused with various herbs and
spices and which were at first seemed
strictly as medicine when distilling
spread to Europe it was through the
usual havens for medical knowledge
religious houses by 1269 Dutch monks
were producing a special juniper based
spirit said to cure the plague this was
the birth of what we now call jinn
spirits at that time were drunk by the
rich and after the dissolution of the
monasteries in Britain they were often
produced at home demand was high for who
knew medicine could taste so good by the
17th century spirits or cordials as they
were known were increasingly
commercialized no longer just as
medicines but as Pleasant and it was
claimed healthy tipples meanwhile
British soldiers were fighting alongside
the Dutch as they battled for
independence the shot of Dutch courage
their forces downed before heading off
to do or die became popular with the
Brits - and returning soldiers brought
back with them a taste for this curious
juniper flavored drink it may have
started off as a Dutch drink but it
quickly became very British it was no
longer a rich person's drink it was now
a cheap and tasty way to get hazy and
forget the daily struggle for people
whose lives were often short brutal and
very miserable distilling was easy and
could be done in a basement while the
rats looked on it was especially popular
in London and it was there that it would
cause the most problems in 1688 King
William the 3rd saw an opportunity to
tax King making money to fight the
French he encouraged production and the
gin craze went back for nearly 75 years
gin was blamed for murder and mayhem and
when the government finally tried to
control it there were public loo
chambers of officials trying to inspect
distilleries in the 19th century gin was
rehabilitated although it never lost its
slight air of danger
working-class gin palaces dripping with
glass and
it's made Jin glamorous parking back to
the time when spirits were only for the
rich and making it slightly more
socially respectable it was often drunk
meat or with hot water but a new era was
beginning tonic water has its origins in
South America where the bark of the
cinchona tree was used to treat malaria
as a powder it was mixed with water and
sugar and it spread across the British
Empire but it was only in the 18th
century when carbonated water was
invented but it made the leap from a
fairly vile medicine to everyday drink
it still lacked something though and it
was in the heat of the British colonies
such as those in India that people
started adding gin for an extra kick gin
and tonic
was born today gin is as popular as ever
in 2009 laws have change to allow
small-scale distilleries to produce gin
more easily all the reasons it was
popular in the past are just as valid
today it's easy to produce endlessly
buried who mixes well with other drinks
no wonder we get through so much of the
stuff Cheers
[Music]
you